progress in AI is increasingly hidden
behind closed doors but not all of those
doors are locked so let's piece together
what we do know we know for example that
open AI are targeting particular AI
agent benchmarks and I'll give you the
highlights of two papers to Showcase
what that might mean and no this is not
a video on that new chat GPT task
feature which I tried to find
interesting but I just couldn't
meanwhile though samman markedly changes
gear on takeoff speeds in other words
how fast super intelligence is coming
while telling the hyp Bros to chill but
deep seek based in China proves that
open source models aren't that far
behind with their new R1 model so
whatever Western Labs cook up could well
be served to all in short order whether
any of this honestly affects your work
directly this year will more depend on
how digital your work is and how
quantifiable or Benchmark it is that to
be honest will give you the best gauge
of what 2025 will mean for you with AI
but first I want to give you some
numbers and I don't just mean the cost
of 03 when it is released which
apparently will be still $200 on the pro
tear given that they are already losing
money with 01 Pro it does kind of make
you wonder about the economics of
serving out o03 Pro for $200 a month but
let's see what happens no I more mean
the numbers behind the operator system
that open aai looks set to be releasing
quite soon we can already Glimpse
options to toggle on the computer use
agent or operator or force it to quit
and stop I'll get to the two relevant
papers in a moment but at face value if
the O Series has proven anything from
open aai it's proven that it can rapidly
improve in any domain that can be
benchmarked so is that why yesterday we
got this headline in a
coming soon PhD level super agents it's
a decently long article but I'm just
going to give you the two or three
highlights a top company possibly open
aai in the coming weeks will announce a
breakthrough that unleashes quote PhD
level super agents to do complex human
tasks that's all their words not mine
that denomination of PhD level is highly
disputed of course openai CEO samman has
scheduled a closed door briefing for US
government officials on the 30th of
January and there's not much other
information in the article other than
this sentence several open AI staff have
been telling friends that they are both
jazzed and spooked by recent progress
now while that's vague we already know
publicly that openai are hiring
aggressively for a multi-agent research
team which also specializes in equipping
models to do more with tools think teams
of Agents each one of which specialized
in the apps and tools you use on your
your computer open AI want you to be
able to delegate tasks that would take a
long time to complete and involve
complex environments with multiple
agents this is something that they are
Marching towards this year of course if
fulfilled that could mean the massive
disruption and dislocation of jobs in
the medium term according to one White
House National Security adviser this was
again an exclusive in axios and that
adviser by the way spoke with an urgency
and directness that was rarely heard
during his decade Plus in public life
suffice to say though the first version
of this computer use operator agent from
openai According to leaks won't be
capable of much of any of that it can't
yet reliably generate profits or issue
meme coins although I doubt open AI
would release a model that could as we
enter this year of AI agents doing our
work for us what can we expect from this
first version of open ai's computer use
agent what kind of tasks are involved in
web Voyager and OS world how about this
one where you type search Apple for the
accessory smartfolio for iPad and check
the closest pickup availability next to
this ZIP code that is pretty cool that
the agent could do that my only question
is that would take me quite a while to
type out I mean I guess I could speak
that to the agent but if I was typing it
out by the time I type that out I
probably could have got the answer just
by browsing the web this one's kind of
cool find this particular recipe that
takes less than 30 minutes to prepare
pair and has at least a fourstar rating
based on user reviews I think stuff like
this is going to work because you could
just immediately verify if it's giving
you something that meets your criteria
likewise for Amazon searches I could
well imagine listing a bunch of criteria
for something that I want to buy and it
just popping up with the item that match
that criteria definitely not a long
Horizon task in a complex environment
but it's a start the task in the OS
World Benchmark seems to be somewhat
harder the prompt was I illegally
downloaded an episode of Friends to
practice listening but I don't know how
to remove the subtitles please help me
remove the subtitles now this is the
kind of thing that I am looking forward
to honestly it takes me like an hour at
least sometimes two to edit these videos
in Des script and I'm looking for an
agent that can kind of mimic my style of
editing and just like immediately edit
these videos why can't existing agents
already crush the simpler tasks well
apparently more than 75% of their clicks
are inaccurate must be pretty
frustrating to be an AI agent that's
repeatedly clicking the screen and not
being able to click the right thing oh
and also they were attracted by
advertisement content which affects
their judgment just imagine you in the
future having given your credit card to
an AI agent and watching helpless as it
clicks on an ad and buys a random
product now I know the flaws of Agents
can seem silly sometimes and like we're
years and years away from usable agents
but let me give you a little anecdote
just almost for fun one time years ago I
created over 200 Pages worth of
mathematics puzzles and quizzes with
explainers now as it happened those
quizzes proved really quite useful to
Benchmark early AI models like the
original chat GPT and as you probably
experiened yourself those early models
like again the original chat GPT flopped
hard on pretty much all of the questions
except the most simple calculation ones
fast forward 2 years years after the
initial release of chat gbt and 01 when
I got access crushed pretty much every
single question this is 01 in Pro mode
obviously there had been incremental
progress before that but even tougher
challenges like this one o1 pro a so I
guess I'm saying that I feel like we
will go from laughing at AI agents to
being super impressed with them in
actually less than 2 years this time
possibly within this calendar year and I
Echo what gome Brown said who is a lead
researcher on the O Series of models
when he said it can be hard to quote
feel the AGI until you see an AI surpass
top humans in a domain you care deeply
about competitive coders will feel it
within a couple of years he said then
when he refers to Paul he's talking
about the writer behind taxi driver who
said the AI came up with better script
ideas than he could and he said Paul is
early but I think writers will feel it
too everyone will have their leid old
moment at a different time of course the
legendary player at go who was beaten by
Alpha go and I don't think that's
necessarily contradictory with this post
that he said earlier lots of vague AI
hype on social media these days of
course there are good reasons to be
optimistic about further progress but
plenty of Unsolved research problems
remain now speaking of vague hype though
that issue is not helped by none other
than the CEO of open AI who has reversed
his position on Fast takeoff timelines
first let me give you his current
opinion as of a week ago what's
something you've rethought recently on
AI or changed your mind about I think a
fast takeoff is more possible than I
thought a couple of years ago how fast
feels hard to reason about but something
that's in like a small number of years
rather than a decade wow what do you
think is the worst advice people are
given on adapting to ai ai is hitting a
wall which I think is the laziest and
way to try to not think about it and
just you know put it out of sight out of
M now let me play you a brief extract
from a video I just published on my
patreon about what he thought just 18
months ago or so short timelines and
slow takeoff will be a pretty good call
it's the prediction he would make but
the way people Define the start of the
takeoff reaching the human Baseline may
make it seem otherwise of course in an
Ideal World we would have clearer
communication from these companies about
just what the frontier is but we don't
live in that world and honestly it is
hard to keep up some sometimes with the
changing opinions of the CEOs of these
AI labs when open AI was founded Sam
wman said obviously this is too Elon
Musk would comply with and aggressively
support all AI regulation 18 months ago
he personally implored Congress to
regulate Ai and I covered that at the
time but then this week we got this very
corporate economic blueprint from open
AI which was not fun to read in full in
short though it implores the US
government not to stunt AI through
regulation later in the document it's
promised that openai would never
facilitate their tools being used to
threaten or coers other states meanwhile
that principle doesn't always seem to be
top of Mind of open AI CEO the anthropic
CEO who chose not to make such a
donation did say this about the stakes
for 2025 and his sense of urgency on
regulating Ai and and I feel I feel
urgency I really think we need to do
something in 2025 if we get to the end
of 202
and we've still done nothing about this
then I'm going to be worried I don't
know if you guys remember the days where
companies used to take 6 to 8 months to
safety test their models before release
and open source was claimed to be at
least a year behind the frontier these
days speaking to official safety testers
and others and correct me if you feel
differently but it feels like get the
model out as soon as you possibly can
and no open source does not feel like a
year behind as proven by Deep seek R1 it
was announced Ed literally an hour and a
half ago while I'm filming the video so
no I haven't read the paper in full but
I have digested some of the Benchmark
results and noticed that the pricing by
the way is like 95% cheaper than for
example 01 when it comes to Output
tokens now you might agree with me at
this stage That official benchmarks tell
a less than they used to and that each
of us really should come up with our own
Benchmark and see which model performs
best I will say it didn't do
particularly well on my Benchmark simple
bench this is just on the public set of
questions we are going to do a full run
very soon let me know if you experience
the same but it repeatedly says wait no
wait I'm going to do this wait no I'm
going to do something else but more
seriously when the open AI operator or
computer use agent comes out it will be
very interesting to see how quickly
Chinese Labs can catch up with that the
fact by the way that open ai's O Series
sometimes thinks in its Chain of Thought
in Chinese is perhaps a story for
another video of course 2025 won't only
be about agents we're also set to see
the merger of the GPT series and the O
Series that would be really interesting
and I will be honest here you know the
model that I'm actually looking forward
to the most that would be Claude for
Sonet I was spending about 50 hours the
last 10 days or so working on this
coding project with a colleague and
there's one critical task that we needed
an llm to do
and 01 Pro simply couldn't get the hang
of it but Claude 3.5 did almost
instantly I know that super anecdotal
and I'll be telling you much more about
what we're working on soon but that was
quite a powerful moment for me and
speaking of powerful moments I honestly
think you might have just a few while
listening to the 880,000 hours podcast
yes they are the sponsors of this video
but I genuinely listen to them and
really learn a lot for example this
podcast 209 I was listening to while on
a long walk in London really interesting
of course all the shenanigans that are
going on with the nonprofit oversight of
open AI yes by the way they also have a
YouTube channel that I know some of you
have already checked out and like so
thank you for checking it out thank you
also to everyone who has participated in
the simple bench competition which runs
for another 11 days lots more to say on
that front in another video honestly let
me know what you think will this be the
year of super agents or is Twitter hype
out of control again for me as ever the
truth lies somewhere in between thank
you so much for watching and have a
wonderful day